ok let's get into audience questions for
the week first question today hey David
are you now ready to get off Facebook
after yet another data breach you know
my answer is no and it's not because of
any personal attachment to Facebook it's
just a really big thing for the show
like we to do a lot of the things if I
could get rid of my personal presence on
Facebook but continue doing all the show
stuff that we do I would really consider
getting off of Facebook but the truth is
the way Facebook works they're supposed
to have a profile that is for a real
person right so me doing like a fake
profile with some bogus invented
identity it's not really what you're
supposed to do we really don't want to
jeopardize the status of the show's
ability to reach people and distribute
our content on Facebook so I do use my
real Facebook account to manage the show
stuff and it's mostly that but what has
been going on with Facebook's data
breach has been absolutely horrible and
atrocious we were all logged out of our
accounts over the weekend and it
disconnected our ability to manage show
related content we had to reconnect and
reoffend to Kate because of that data
breach and its disaster after disaster
it's just such a big platform they have
so many users and we would be putting
ourselves at it as a at a disadvantage
if we were to get off of Facebook I
agree sure there are other social media
sites out there but you can't do the
same things on Facebook as you can on
like Twitter and Instagram and snapchat
it's sure not the same thing
increasingly our VR videos that are
directly uploaded to Facebook are
getting more and more views we are now
part of Facebook's monetization program
for for ads on videos which is a big
thing so if people are hearing me say
I'm not getting off of it because we
need it to run our business and that's
bad I mean I would just argue I don't
know that that's actually really bad I
mean we exist people consume content on
Facebook and you kind of have to be
where the people are it's like if we
said we're gonna get off of YouTube
because of what Google did that led to
them being fined in Europe it's like
okay well then the show is probably over
because we have you know 8 to 10 million
views a month on YouTube so we could do
that but in the long run are we doing
more good by virtue of having our
content on these platforms then
the statement that would be made by
saying we're pulling the show off
YouTube and we're pulling it off
Facebook Alex Jones wasn't he didn't
make the decision himself he was pushed
off of those platforms and he's in
serious trouble right now so I am NOT
belittling in any way what it is that
has been going on with Facebook but we
I'm not getting off of Facebook but what
I will say is for years like every
couple months when I log in it says
please give us your phone number to make
it easier to recover your account in the
case that you're locked out I've never
done that and I am glad that I've not
given Facebook my number yeah that's
that's probably a good move and
certainly I don't trust these other
social media websites with my data it's
not like just because Facebook is awful
at it that these other sites are gonna
be great with it I agree well I mean
what can you do
what can you do it's an appeal to
futility do you find that you still are
like making plans with people by
communicating via Facebook now those
days are over
oh they are those days are over how are
you communicating with people now
there's text messaging okay I mean
that's that's all you need I mean I
guess the the Facebook groups and the
pages can be useful but or I haven't
found a reason for it
are you on any like vegan groups or
anything like that I may actually be
kind of embarrassing that well I am I
have to get off of those right away if
you got our Facebook you would no longer
have that shared insight and community
that that provides you I'm increasingly
using whatsapp actually to communicate
with people and honestly I don't really
know exactly what the deal is in terms
of their data sharing and and whatnot
but I don't have what's that are they
owned by Facebook whatsapp yeah oh I
have no idea let's look at them anyway
supposedly they have end-to-end
encryption know what that means but it
sounds good
I fall for the marketing I fall for the
marketing of it no it's actually because
for people who are not in the u.s.
texting can be pricey so whatsapp is
just a much easier way to work with them
yep I just looked it up whatsapp is
owned by Facebook there you go so I'm
doing nothing apparently so that's
that's part of Facebook all right send
me your thoughts are you getting off of
Facebook how are you using Facebook is
this the final straw when it comes to
Facebook